we do have an early leader in the latest
section Megan Lee with two incredible
victories this one with the black pieces
against a former Champion tell us about
that how do you feel right now uh it's
pretty exciting um I'm just taking one
game at a time
um and this one was not an easy one
because she was putting a lot of
pressure from the beginning she
surprised you in the opening with this
aggressive Scotch tell us a bit about
that yeah I wasn't expecting her to play
the scotch um
I think it's a little hard when you're
unfamiliar with like the setups to
figure out like a plan to do for both
white and black so since she hasn't
played it a lot I think she struggled a
little bit with coming up with a plan
for what to do and when did you feel
like her preparation finished
uh the rage 4 it felt like she still
knows exactly I think after she played
like Knight F3 she took like 20 minutes
or so so this was the big moment yeah
I do have three and you played Bishop A6
C4 C5
Knight to C6 Bishop to D2
and this was the critical moment after
D3 Knight to D2 it felt like she's
backing down a little bit did you feel
the same way uh yeah I think she spent a
lot of tempo moving her night around
while I was able to finish my
development so
um I think she has to play really
precisely otherwise it's a bit hard how
did you assess this position and how did
you come up with your plan for the next
few moves I was thinking after I played
H6 that I could try a break with G5 or
maybe play G4 so I think she was worried
about that um
but she played some moves to prevent it
so I came up with this other plan and I
think she missed Knight takes E5 here oh
Knight dc5 yeah this was the big one and
if she takes back you just go Bishop F6
open up set up this pin on the e-file
and then follow it up with this pick up
the bishop for free very nice very nice
maneuver found by you and nice tactics
E4 to B1 did you feel like you have full
control of the position at this point
yeah I think my pieces are pretty active
and I was I think I was able to maintain
the initiative here exchange the Queens
if possible and just take advantage of
your extra material very nice victory
for you Megan what are your Ambitions
coming into this event are you thinking
about that title at all no I'm not
thinking about it I think I'm just
trying to play my best chess I spend a
lot of time working at my job where it's
hard to find time to play chess so I'm
glad I was able to make time this time
how do you combine the two training for
such a big daughter on the weekends yeah
works pretty tiring
excellent guys join the conversation
just our congratulations indeed to you
Megan and keep up the good work go
Huskies
congratulations congratulations
very good and uh